>> Bret: THANK YOU.
LET'S GET SOME PERSPECTIVE ON
THIS.
SENIOR POLITICAL ANALYST
BRIT HUME JOINS US.
GOOD EVENING.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE DEMOCRAT
MEMO, THE FALLOUT FROM IT.
>> I HAVE READ BOTH OF THE MEMOS
CAREFULLY AND THE REPUBLICAN
MEMO ASSERTS THE FBI AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT MADE IMPROPER USE OF
THIS SO-CALLED DOSSIER WHICH IS
A COLLECTION OF, YOU KNOW, TO
SOME EXTENT, TO A CONSIDERABLE
EXTENT UNVERIFIED MATERIAL.
A LOT OF IT SALACIOUS, AS YOU
HEARD CATHERINE REPORT, QUOTING
COMEY.
ACQUIRING A WARRANT TO SPY ON
CARTER PAGE WEDDING -- THEY MADE
CARTER PAGE WEDDING -- THEY MADH
CARTER PAGE WEDDING -- THEY MADA
CARTER PAGE WEDDING -- THEY MADY
USE OF THE DOSSIER WHICH WAS AN
IMPROPER BASIS FOR A WARRANT AND
THAT THEY FAIL TO INFORM THE
COURT OF THE EXTENT TO WHICH
THIS WAS A PARTISAN DOCUMENT
BASICALLY PAID FOR BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
THE DEMOCRATIC MEMO ATTEMPTS TO
REBUT IT BUT IT DOESN'T REALLY
DO THAT.
IT SAYS THAT THERE WAS A LOT OF
OTHER SOLID MATERIAL USED AS THE
BASIS FOR THE WARRANT BUT IF
THAT WERE TRUE, THEN WHY BRING
THE DOSSIER INTO IT AT ALL, IF
THEY HAD PLENTY OF OTHER BASES
FOR THE WARRANT?
THE SECOND THING THAT DEMOCRATS
ARGUE IS THAT THE COURT WAS
PROPERLY INFORMED TO THE EXTENT
TO WHICH THIS WAS A PARTISAN
DOCUMENT.
I HAVE READ THE QUOTE IN THE
DEMOCRAT MEMO, AND IT'S A
MASTERPIECE OF CIRCUMLOCUTION,
ENDING UP WITH ONLY THE VAGUEST
ATTRIBUTION OF THIS DOCUMENT TO
POLITICS.
IT CERTAINLY DOESN'T TELL THE
JUDGE THAT THIS WAS SOMETHING
PAID FOR BY THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
AND THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THOSE ARE KIND OF THE CENTRAL
ALLEGATIONS THAT WE ARE DEALING
WITH AND I DON'T THINK IT'S
EFFECTIVELY REBUTTED BY THE
DEMOCRATIC MEMO.
>> Bret: I SAW YOUR COMMENTS
OVER THE WEEKEND ON TWITTER.
ANDREW McCARTHY HAD A PRETTY
DETAILED PACE POINT BY POINT
ABOUT SOME OF THIS.
IN THE NATIONAL REVIEW.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
INTERESTING IS TO LISTEN TO THE
DEMOCRATS WHO HAD A REAL PROBLEM
PRIOR TO THE NUNES MEMO COMING
OUT WARNING ABOUT A THREAT TO
NATIONAL SECURITY.
YET THIS MEMO IS REDACTED PRETTY
HEAVILY BECAUSE SOURCES AND
METHODS ARE IN THIS MEMO.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THE DEMOCRATS.
REMEMBER GOING BACK TO THE TIME
WHEN THE REPUBLICAN MEMO WAS
FIRST ABOUT TO EMERGE AND THE
DEMOCRATS HAD A MEMO AS A
REBUTTAL.
THE DEMOCRATS ON THE COMMITTEE
WERE PREPARED TO HAVE BOTH MEMOS
RELEASED RIGHT AWAY.
AND THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
THE REPUBLICAN MEMO WAS PUT
THROUGH A PROCESS.
THE DEMOCRATIC MEMO WENT THROUGH
THE SAME PROCESS LATER.
THE REPUBLICAN MEMO WAS FOUND TO
HAVE VERY LITTLE IF ANYTHING
THAT REVEALED SOURCES AND
METHODS.
THERE WERE NO REDACTIONS.
THE DEMOCRATIC MEMO COMES ALONG,
THEY WERE PREPARED TO RELEASE IT
WITHOUT FURTHER REVIEW AND IT'S
LACED WITH REDACTIONS MADE AT
THE SUGGESTION OF THE FBI AND
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO PROTECT
SOURCES AND METHODS.
IT IS A PECULIAR THING FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEY PRODUCED A MEMO THAT
APPEARS TO HAVE HAD AN ARRAY OF